[Música]
una de las grandes preguntas y de las
grandes incógnitas que deja el
fallecimiento de la reina isabel segunda
es cuál fue la causa de su muerte al
respecto se ha dicho poco y para hablar
del tema nos acompaña en nuestro estudio
nuestra periodista especializada en
salud más romeros a la mar bienvenida
muchas gracias maría clara bueno yo soy
que usted no tiene la respuesta a la
gran pregunta que todos están haciendo
pero que sabemos hasta hoy de las causas
de su muerte pues como tú bien decías se
maneja con mucha prudencia y realmente
más allá de ese escueto comunicado que
llevamos repitiendo desde ayer de que
murió en paz en el castillo de balmoral
pues no sabemos bien a qué se debe y
además también cabe destacar que no es
extraño que no se digan los motivos de
la muerte de algún de la monarquía de
los miembros de la monarquía del reino
unido- esto ha pasado también por
ejemplo con su abuelo con su padre que
nunca hubo mucha claridad alrededor de
estos hechos también con esa idea de
mantener un poco como esa imagen de que
las monarquías no se pueden tocar a que
no les toca lo mismo que nos toca a todo
el mundo pero sí es verdad también que
los últimos dos años habían crecido los
motivos de preocupación alrededor del
reina en octubre de 2021 fue
hospitalizada una noche también sucedió
en noviembre y no se dieron mayores
explicaciones más allá de esos problemas
de movilidad que se siguen aduciendo
desde entonces que además digamos que no
son extraños para alguien de 96 años
también uno de los grandes sustos fue en
febrero de 2022 cuando se anunció que se
había contagiado de kobe 19 además pocos
días después de haberse encontrado con
su hijo la hora rey carlos tercero que
también había dado positivo aunque
tampoco se informó ver si realmente esa
había sido la cadena de transmisión o
era otra porque había varios contagios
que se reportaron el palacio de
buckingham en esas fechas finalmente la
última información médica que tenemos de
esa preocupación por la salud de la
reina que supimos ayer y que nos puso a
todos en alerta pero más allá de esto el
resto que realmente podemos decir es
pura especulación así que preferimos
pues no decir nada más para no entrar en
esos juegos tampoco y claro es que
históricamente el palacio de buckingham
ha sido muy reservado sobre dar detalles
sobre la salud de los miembros de la
familia real y tal como usted lo decía
lo vimos cuando la reina se contagió de
kobe 19 que poco se informó
cuando estábamos viendo y se acercaba a
la muerte de felipe el duque de
edimburgo y el esposo de la reina
también se supo muy poco y ahora tal
como usted lo dice el comunicado de ayer
cuando la reina estaba enferma era los
médicos están preocupados sin mayores
detalles entonces quizás la causa de la
muerte no se sabrá en un buen tiempo
pero entonces pasemos a otro tema del
que de pronto si se pueda saber más y
que también está muy relacionado con lo
que todos se preguntan y es quién es el
equipo clínico encargado de cuidar a la
reina y ahora al rey carlos tercero
porque todos se imaginarán que son los
mejores profesionales pues así es
exactamente estos médicos que estaban
preocupados nosotros nos quisimos
preguntar quiénes son y es que el
palacio de buckingham cuenta con un
equipo médico 24 horas disponibles para
la reina y también para otros miembros
de la familia real el director es del
profesor sergio tomás es un
gastroenterólogo pero que sin embargo
lleva al servicio de la reina desde hace
16 años y desde 2014 como jefe algo
particularmente interesante es de que
este cargo existe desde mil
557 entonces histórico de la monarquía
también tener a un médico dedicado a
cuidar la salud además está totalmente
involucrado en la salud de la familia
real acompaño en los dos últimos partes
de la duquesa de cambridge kate
middleton entonces también pues vemos
eso no como esta tradición del cuidado
médico a los reyes y a las reinas de
inglaterra y queremos explicar algo
totalmente particular que es la historia
de este del abuelo en este caso de la
reina el rey jorge quinto que murió en
1936 su médico particular era el hort
dawson y lo que explicaron lo que se
reveló digamos fueron como cuatro cuatro
décadas cinco décadas incluso después de
su muerte es que le administró una dosis
letal de morfina y de cocaína digamos
para guiar hacia la muerte al rey que
estaba ya en coma y que estaba sufriendo
y además uno de los motivos que este
hombre explicaba en sus diarios que fue
así como se reveló que había pues
ayudado a morir al rey fue que para que
la muerte de jorge quinto pudiera ser
anunciada en los diarios de la mañana
que tenían algo más de reputación que en
esa época que los diarios de la tarde
bastante interesante esta historia de
eutanasia dentro de la familia real hace
muchísimas décadas cuando todavía esta
muerte digna no era legal y no era
aprobada oficialmente el reino unido de
hecho en reino unido- se aprobó en 2002
y sigue siendo para casos muy
específicos estamos hablando de una
muerte de
1936 algo que digamos pone sobre la mesa
al menos o abre el debate sobre la
muerte digna quién tiene derecho a morir
dignamente y quiénes no en el mundo de
hoy y también en otro rasgo interesante
es estas figuras cómo cambian y cómo se
tiene por un lado el símbolo y una
figura como tal y por otro quién lo
ocupa sucede con el rey o la reina del
reino unido- que van cambiando pero la
figura del monarca permanece y lo mismo
la figura del médico de cabecera del
monarca por supuesto así es en realidad
es bastante lógico pensar que unas
personas que tienen tanta significación
en la política internacional en la vida
del reino unido pues tengan que estar
bien cuidados claro y ahora otra de las
grandes preguntas que se hace el reino
unido y el mundo es como la reina isabel
segunda logró durar 96 años ha sido
la monarca que más tiempo ha durado en
reino unido- y que más ha gobernado y yo
le tengo una historia al respecto y es
que en londres hay un comentario medio
jocoso medio leyenda sobre por qué la
reina duraba tanto y es que se decía que
tradicionalmente en reinounido los
hombres beben whisky a las 5 o 6 de la
tarde y las mujeres ginebra y que la
reina como buena como buena mujer
británica siempre tomaba su ginebra y
jocosamente los británicos comentaban
que esto fue el secreto de su larga vida
una ginebra siempre en la tarde si no
tienes toda la razón de hecho hay
infinidad de publicaciones cuando pones
en google este tipo de búsquedas que
hablan de estos secretos de la
longevidad de la reina desde la ginebra
hasta otras cosas productos hábitos no
también como reforzando esta imagen de
que la reina era una modelo a seguir
pero la verdad déjame decirte que hoy
deberíamos decir que la ingesta de
alcohol no es recomendable y dudamos
profundamente envasadas a las evidencias
científicas que fuera el secreto de la
longevidad de la reina pero yo tengo
otras explicaciones
una de las publicaciones de las que
hablábamos estas publicaciones que
ensalzan la buena salud y los buenos
hábitos de la reina es un artículo
publicado en la bbc que destaca esa
buena actividad física esa buena hábitos
alimentarios nunca fumar su padre bueno
hay historia de tabaquismo en su familia
entonces ella nunca fumó o no y una de
las cosas que destacan es su genética la
madre de la reina isabel sabemos que
vivió hasta los buenos superó los 100
años pero en realidad explicamos que se
cree que la genética sólo es responsable
de alrededor de un 20 por ciento de la
longevidad y que el resto son los
hábitos alrededor de eso y otra cosa que
decían era que era el matrimonio no que
la felicidad del matrimonio fue lo que
le dio la longevidad a la reina tampoco
podemos respaldar eso con ningún tipo de
evidencia científica pero en cualquier
caso la verdad es que la longevidad de
la reina probablemente se corresponde a
la esperanza de vida de las familias más
ricas de reino unido se sabe que la
esperanza de vida entre las clases más
bajas para las mujeres en reino unidos
de 78 años la de las clases más ricas
desde 86 una diferencia de 8 años de
vida que da el estatus social entonces
es adecuado decir que en este caso ayudo
vivir como una reina increíble todos los
factores que hay de por medio para que
la reina lograra vivir más tiempo mar
gracias por el informe muchas gracias a
ti y nosotros terminamos así este
cubrimiento especial pero sigan
conectados porque en france 24 minutos
les tendremos muchísima más información
[Música]